barrio Jackson in tears addressing the
bachelor in paradise scandal I know I'm
not that that monster that they're
trying to portray on TV on Tuesday
night's be IP the much-anticipated
sit-down between Demario Jackson and
host Chris Harrison aired two months
after allegations of misconduct between
Demario and cast mate Corrine elympios
temporarily shut down production on
season four even on the way home you
didn't really know the gravity of this
situation I when I left it was just I'm
getting kicked off and that Quran was
gonna be kicked off as well I never once
thought that I would be here like today
sweet on you guys in the middle of a
crazy scandal Mario got extremely
emotional over his mother's reaction to
the scandal I love my mom more than
anything in this world like seeing her
cry every single day and just it was
difficult they're like I'm her
everything like best friends and it was
difficult so I had to like make her
deactivate everything because she was
going to war like I defended me and it
yeah man it sucks
he sat down with Demario last week where
he opened up about how he got through
this difficult time so you went into
therapy for this oh yeah definitely
I mean I had to there was I just had so
many I mean I didn't sleep
I didn't sleep from that Sunday I'm
sorry that Monday to like that I want to
sell like that Friday
so like shed some light on it is that I
have 20-plus brothers and sisters who
are all in this with me and other cast
mates from previous seasons have reached
out to me as well it's one thing to talk
to your mother and your father or you
know it's like my lawyer or my PR or
something but it's another thing to talk
to cast mates who actually have
experienced this and who have lived this
crazy reality world tune in next week
for currents take on what happened in
paradise